on Windows I'll open the command prompt
and CD to the Downloads folder and this
time I want to use FC to compare game
old days to game new Jas so I'll scroll
back up to the top and I can see that
I'm comparing the files game old days
and game new Jas and there's a few
different changes here so I'll have to
look through for a little bit but if I
scroll down here's the typo
space are that's not right on Mac or
Linux the process is very similar I'll
open the terminal CD to the Downloads
folder then run the command diff - you
game old Jas game new Jas the diff is in
a slightly different format than when I
ran this on Windows but the content is
the same
if I scroll back up here's the typo I'll
go ahead and open the game Jas file
search for space are and here it is I'll
change it back to space now now we'll go
ahead and try out the new controls I can
move now but it's harder to play the
game since I only have two hands because
enter is a bit far from the arrow keys I
think I'll change the controls back now
I'm going to hand you over to Sarah to
reflect on what you just accomplished